[Música]
hola ustedes lo conocen a cosimo consumo
es un personaje un cuento de macedonio
fernández a este personaje le habían
extraído quirúrgicamente la capacidad de
percibir el futuro y vivía enamorado del
presente sin poder anticipar nada ni
bueno ni malo que le pudiera ocurrir ni
siquiera podía darse cuenta de que se
lleva su propia muerte
de alguna manera nosotros como sociedad
somos un poco como cosimo nos iremos muy
enamorados donde el hoy sin pensar
demasiado en el mañana estamos
convencidos de que mañana se va a
repetir exactamente igual que hoy pero
existe nosotros ningún tipo de
anticipación o preparación con el tiempo
nos fuimos convenciendo de que es
difícil generar los cambios
de alguna manera nos convencimos y nos
fueron convenciendo de que es imposible
hacerlo
somos así un poco como conocimos nos jan
kees posibilidad de pensar en el futuro
como algo que nosotros podemos construir
nos movemos entre
fantasías estos mágicos no sabemos un
poco entre profecías autocumplidas esto
no es para mí no lo voy a alegrar
a tiempo y también efectos pigmalión
estos alumnos son de 7 aquellos aprenden
matemáticas
esto nos llegará quinto
no está mal que tratemos de anticipar
los fracasos para evitarlos lo malo es
que pensemos que es lo único que nos
puede llegar a pasar
la realidad es que en las aulas
usualmente no vemos chicos que estén
entusiasmados con el futuro cómo van a
estarlo sino conciben el futuro como una
infinidad de posibilidades
porque los pases son y tal vez porque
nos escuchan a nosotros todo el tiempo
decir una y otra vez frases como lo
intentó lo intento y no puedo lograrlo
nada cambia todo es lo mismo sólo se
repite me esfuerzo me esfuerzo
somos nosotros los adultos los que vamos
construyendo un paisaje que es poco
motivador
queríamos ver el discurso con estas
lógicas mágicas y algún que otro decir
cumplido la ilusión de que el futuro
está dado que está prescripto el sexo es
destino y no queda otra cosa más que
dejarse llevar
de alguna manera somos nosotros los que
vamos contagiando esa falta de
expectativa a las generaciones que nos
siguen
la escuela es un mecanismo económico
para educar a las masas para educar a
muchos nos educa a todos pero a todos de
la misma manera esa escuela y para
romper justamente esas lógicas de
pensamiento mágico la escuela está ahí
para desafiar esas ideas la escuela está
ahí para darnos a nosotros las
habilidades que necesitamos para
enfrentar el futuro para incluirnos en
una sociedad y para hacerlo de manera
exitosa la escuela tiene que asumir el
rol de ayudar a otros a crear opciones a
pensar en múltiples escenarios de futuro
pero lamentablemente la escuela está
fallando y nosotros no sabemos por qué
no estamos alcanzando los resultados que
esperamos y mientras esa escuela
lo estamos logrando que se cristalizó un
modelo nuevo la pregunta que me hizo un
profesor y mientras tanto y mientras
tanto podemos hacer muchas cosas para ir
al menos rompiendo gracias
la escuela que yo hice a mí me ayudó a
pensar en el futuro me preguntó que
quería hacerlo hacer la escuela que yo
hice me dijo ya que prepararme para el
futuro de hecho me contó muy convencida
cómo iba a ser ese futuro
la verdad es que cuando ese futuro se
presentó no tenía nada que ver con lo
que me había contado era mucho más
heterogéneo mucho más complejo muchísimo
más dinámico y si bien error algunas
cosas acertó en otras por lo menos si me
hizo pensar en que tenía que prepararme
y que tenía que empezar y que tenía que
ensayar eso que yo quería hacer o hacer
y algunas de esas cosas soy o hago ahora
la escuela falla y el futuro se repite y
se repite porque en el presente nada
estamos cambiando malo pero conocidos
la escuela repite modelos e incluso hace
cosas que vemos que no funcionan
nos pasamos la mayor parte del tiempo
leyendo cuando sabemos que sólo el 10%
de lo que leemos somos capaces de
retener oyendo cuando solo retenemos el
20 por ciento de lo que oímos y memories
una enorme cantidad de datos y hechos
que no sabemos si en algún momento de la
vida necesitar porque el modelo de
escuela es un modelo prescriptivo
[Música]
hay cosas que la escuela no hacemos a
los alumnos casi no le dejamos decidir
absolutamente nada le preguntamos todo y
a todos le pasamos por igual las mismas
formas las mismas metas los mismos
caminos los chicos en la escuela
aprenden cómo se aprender fuera de
acumular evaluamos más pensando en
cuanto que en cómo
esto también tiene que ver con
productivista un modelo que piensa que
el otro es incapaz de que hay que
proveerle todo
serán capaces
de alguna manera esta escuela tiene que
recrearse de alguna manera tenemos que
repensar la tenemos que darle al alumno
y al docente otros lugares otros roles
nosotros tenemos que empezar a pensar
cómo podemos crear esta escuela al menos
como lo que es con lo que tenemos la
escuela ahora es un lugar para aprender
saberes sabidos para aprender saberes
que han sido ya muy validados por la
escuela o deberían ser solamente hola
debería ser un lugar para empezar a
generar proyectos para empezar a
aprender otras competencias estamos
frente a un cambio de era ya lo sabemos
pero seguimos usando los mecanismos y
las ideas construidas en otro tiempo y
las seguimos aplicando y esperamos que
den un resultado distinto la verdad es
que probablemente no lo van a dar
autores como daniel pink e incluso ya
nos dicen que hay que pensar con el otro
lado del cerebro hay que empezar a
generar otras habilidades que tienen que
ver con empezar a leer oportunidades que
tienen que empezar a tener relación con
otras personas con empezar a crear mitos
narrativas con buscar la belleza
estética que tiene que ver con combinar
ideas disímiles en otras absolutamente
nuevas que tiene que ver con entender
las sutilezas de las interacciones
humanas una escuela que nos enseñe a
nosotros a ser felices con nosotros
mismos y con nosotros a crear proyectos
propios y compartidos una escuela que
empiece a buscar tiempos para crear
significados
[Música]
esta escuela todavía no está pero esta
escuela no tiene un costo no necesita
una estructura necesita solamente un
cambio de miradas necesitamos que los
alumnos empiecen a adquirir las
habilidades que decimos que son del
futuro todo el tiempo hablamos de
innovaciones pero nos cuesta despejar la
idea de innovación de un aparato y una
tecnología y muchas veces las
innovaciones tienen que ver con el
quehacer y como el cómo miramos eso qué
hacemos
necesitamos habilidades de futuro que
tienen que ver con hacer proyectos tomar
el control propio porvenir que tiene que
ver con lo que tienen que ver con
diseñar que tienen que ver con aprender
a aprender esas son las habilidades que
independientemente de cuál sea el futuro
que se nos presente siempre nos van a
servir muy
pero la escuela repite esos modelos
viejos la escuela no está cambiando y
nosotros no estamos haciendo nada para
que esa escuela cambie
de alguna manera nosotros vamos a
repetir ese pasado porque de alguna
manera también es como pensar que lo que
mañana lo vamos a hacer exactamente
igual como lo vivimos hoy
de alguna manera nos resulta sencillo
apegarnos a ese discurso que sostiene el
sistema pero que construimos entre todos
el discurso de que el futuro es uno solo
de que el futuro nos va a llegar de que
todos lo vamos a afrontar de la misma
manera y que todos no necesitamos ningún
tipo de preparación porque si
sobrevivimos hoy y mañana va a ser
exactamente igual que hoy entonces que
necesito cambiar que necesito aprender
para que estaría la escuela
en algún momento del año le hago a mis
alumnos siempre la misma pregunta y les
pregunto qué quieren ser hacer o dónde
quieren estar en dos o cinco años la
mayoría no tiene una respuesta muchos ni
siquiera son capaces de verse en un
tiempo futuro algunos ya están
convencidos independientemente de lo que
hagan no van a cambiar eso que son o
hacer
y atribuyen a causalidades externas lo
bueno y lo malo que le pasa pero como
son externas no tienen control sobre eso
entonces nada los moviliza a avanzar a
aprender a hacer cosas distintas
malo pero conocidos como próximo
viven al menos un poco enamorado de este
presente que están viviendo pero no
están buscando nada distinto para el
mañana
[Música]
yo creo que como docentes principal
función es desafiar estas ideas
desnaturalizarlas nosotros tenemos que
ayudarles a los chicos a pensar a
idealizar a buscar en ese futuro eso que
quieran ser o hacer ayudarles a que por
un momento piensen que no existen los
imposibles que creen proyectos
constantemente que constantemente se
pongan a pensar a idealizar a medirse
por lo menos proyectos de otros a ver si
eso se ajusta a lo que quieren porque
hay que aprender a desear hay que
aprender a desear y hay que saber
hacerlo nosotros como docentes tenemos
que generar esas pequeñas cirugías
reconstructivas que vuelven a habilitar
la parte del cerebro que nos hace creer
que nosotros tenemos el control del
destino que son las decisiones
cotidianas las que nos van llevando al
lugar donde estamos porque si no nos
pasa lo que nos pasa ahora no sabemos
qué decisiones nos trajeron hasta el
lugar en el que estamos ahora y cuando
nos preguntan no tenemos otra cosa más
que decir qué
destinos
y creo que se puede hacer de una manera
muy económica aplicando cuatro cosas la
primera inspirarse
tenemos que buscar aquellas personas
aquellos proyectos aquellas ideas que
nos emocionan que nos mueven de es
también de la que estamos que por lo
menos nos generan expectativas que nos
dan ganas de que nos hagan es creer eso
justamente es que por un momento no
existen los imposibles el segundo paso
tiene que ver con gestionar el propio
talento nosotros tenemos que aprender a
saber en qué somos buenos eso es lo que
nosotros tenemos por aportar y eso es lo
que nos va a ir llevando paso a paso a
alcanzar las metas de ninguna manera
podemos hacerlo si no hacemos una
prospección y no nos vamos conociendo a
nosotros mismos que es un proceso
fundamental pero al mismo tiempo también
tenemos que escuchar a los otros
integrando la voz interior y la mirada
de los otros seguramente vamos a estar
mucho más preparados para afrontar
cualquier meta que nosotros querramos
alcanzar el tercer punto tiene que ver
con generar planeas salir de la fantasía
salir del discurso cuando nosotros lo
presupuestamos cuando le ponemos pasos
cuando le ponemos el valor de cada uno
de los esfuerzos recién ahí estamos en
camino a lograr la meta
hay que hacerse la pregunta y la
pregunta es dispuesto al sacrificio que
implica lograr ese objetivo esa tal vez
sea la medida del deseo que me mueve a
lograrlo
el cuarto punto tiene que ver con
aprender a evaluarnos nuevos alumnos por
resultados sino evaluarlos en un
contexto empezar a detectar esos
pequeños aciertos que logramos todo el
día porque ese es el combustible que nos
mantiene firmes en nuestro camino hacia
la meta que hemos planificado
yo creo que si trabajamos todos en estos
cuatro puntos en cualquiera de los
ámbitos que trabajamos inspirarse
gestionar el talento planificar y
evaluar nos vamos a poder hacer una
educación que no sea un simple llenado
sino que sea una educación
transformadora una educación que nos
invita a pensar que hace que aprender
que diseñar es la tarea que tenemos que
hacer en la escuela en la vida que son
estos que son los que son mejorables que
los podemos cambiar todo el tiempo pero
que toda la vida estamos en proyectos
tenemos que cambiar la mirada del alumno
y hacerle pensar que en blanco no es una
hoja vacía sino una hoja llena de
infinitas posibilidades y para cerrar lo
único que le dejo es una pregunta me
gustaría que piensen que quisieran ser
hacer o ser dentro de dos o cinco años
[Música]
[Aplausos]